my grandma and I went viral and this is
that story now stick with me because we
have a lot to get through so this all
starts in 2011 I am in eighth grade and
like most middle schoolers I just want
to go viral on YouTube I start uploading
videos me dance with my cat and this
channel is totally private every time
someone found out about it in my life I
would just delete it instantly about a
year goes by and I'm now a freshman in
high school one day I'm at my grandma's
house and she's really making me laugh
as she usually does as an experiment I
decided to put my camera at my grandma's
dashboard when she drove me home and I
film the entire thing and she had no
idea that it was recording she was kind
of concerned if the cameras on and I
just said yeah it's for a photography
project and she believes I get home I
edit it put it on YouTube and I decided
to finally make my channel public the
next day wake up to over 20,000 views
and to my 14 year old self
that was going viral and I just I felt
like I finally made it the rest of that
year I continued to upload videos of
myself but also with my grandma and
notice that the grandma video is we're
getting way more views in my head I'm
thinking maybe this channel is meant to
be about me and my grandma I entered
this online comedy contest hosted by
Simon Cowell and I end up winning so I
used the reward money of $2,000 to buy
myself a new computer to start editing
my videos properly and I kept this whole
YouTube thing going keep in mind my
grandma still has no idea that these
videos exist and the internet loves her
honestly after the contest I started to
get a little worried that she was gonna
find these videos or someone's gonna
show them to her what time appear true
Oh snowball on my car I got my car I ran
after that kid because I don't know if
she's gonna freak out on me so the next
year is 2014 and I hit a hundred
thousand subscribers and it just hit me
that this is becoming an actual thing at
this point I'm trying to get my driver's
license and my grandma is my ride to
driver's ed aka a lot of time in the car
together
aka a lot of YouTube con sense I know
what you're thinking
yep she still has no idea I literally
told her that I needed my camera for
driver's ed and that the dashboard was a
safe place for it and she bought it I
started this idea where I start having
conversations with my grandma about pop
culture and
and things that are going on the news
Tara Swift wants go to prom with me
I was able to convince her that Miley
Cyrus was my best friend I went to prom
with Katy Perry and I edged houses with
Justin Bieber it was seriously insane
before I knew it at school on the
Internet I became known as the kid that
convinced his grandma that celebrities
are his friends some of the videos start
getting so many views that my grandma
begins getting recognized in public like
at the grocery store the mall even when
she was driving everyone's eating it up
and my grandma has no idea still I was
in way too deep and knew I had to keep
going though so I told her that all
those people that asked for photos were
my close friends at school and they just
happened to see my class projects okay
do we need a map so it's almost the end
of 2014 I hit 200,000 subscribers and my
grandma literally cannot go to a store
without getting recognized at this point
it was time to come clean in August of
2014 I decided to come clean and show
her all the videos I recorded her live
reaction and she was actually really
happy I thought she was gonna kill me
but to my surprise she wanted to keep
making more and I was just so relieved
this was 2012 now don't leave because
it's about to get crazy up in here I
upload the confession of showing my
grandma her videos and this gets over a
million views within the first week
media outlets all over the globe begin
talking about this random kid that was
able to film his grandma secretly for
years I remember teachers in school even
the ones that didn't like me were
telling me that they saw my story in the
news I'm even driving to school and
listening to my favorite radio station
and randomly talked about my youtube
channel the radio is on because I didn't
have an aux cord by the way there's all
this media buzz stirring around one day
I opened up my email to a message from
Jimmy Kimmel Live honestly I thought the
email is fake but turned out to be real
and they asked I was down to be on the
show via Skype Jimmy wanted me to
convince my grandma that the movie
frozen happened in real life and
secretly record her again Oh gramma you
want to build a snowman when it was so
funny because I wasn't allowed to tell
my grandma that
you're gonna be on the show and she
found out from a friend of the Senior
Center and she actually got so pissed at
me the next year out of the blue were
asked to fly out to California to film a
target commercial my favorite store this
is our first time ever on a plane
together it was our first real trip all
the stuff you need for your dorm room
right grandma coat that summer room 2015
my grandma and I embarked on a road trip
from Connecticut all the way to Chicago
and film the entire thing for web series
that week was probably one of the most
memorable weeks of my entire life and I
really got to see a different side of my
grandma because get trapped in a car
with someone you really see the
different side of them we go to VidCon
my grandma is a full-blown celeb there
everyone's coming up to her asking for
photos and she even tells me that she
feels like Marilyn Monroe
like most grandmas she never expected to
have like fans and so when people were
asking for photos non-stop she at one
point like ran away and was like
heavenly I was working as her assistant
kind of in like monitoring everything
and like making sure the picture is
really running smoothly it was really
cute because she started calling all
these kids her grandchildren and people
were asking for her to adopt them and
she was saying yes even though she knew
all these videos existed she still don't
really understand the whole concept of
YouTube and the Internet and kind of
still thought that these people that
come up to her I know personally cut to
spring 2017 Steve Harvey asked us to be
on his show at little big shots Forever
Young we head to LA again and we talked
to him on his show the premise of his
show is having senior citizens
demonstrate their talents and we don't
really have much talent besides I guess
being funny so we just sat in his couch
and talked about vlogging while other
grandparents were acrobatic and doing
magic after five years of being
youtubers together we decided to spend
some of that YouTube paycheck and get a
trip to Cancun where we spent a week and
just relaxed which brings us to today
we're still making videos together and
she says it actually makes her feel
young it's like her favorite thing to do
and I'm just really happy and relieved
because starting out I was a little
nervous that she'd get mad that I was
doing this and now she's the one calling
me saying like before all this she was
just my grandma we had a normal
relationship and now I'm happy to call
her my best friend I'm just really happy
that this whole experience brought us so
much closer because without it
don't think I'd be as close to third I'm
glad you're laughing I thought you'd be
mad I also think it's really important
to visit your grandparents because a lot
of the time she's just sitting at home
and this is really giving her something
to do what started out as a secret and
something I did not want my grandma to
ever know about now she's the one that
won't shut up about it and is telling
everybody we see to subscribe whether
it's at the restaurant or even at
stoplights and that's just insane
because grandma we're better than that
[Music]